et pour les passagers qui devaient être
transférés ce matin vers orly c'est raté
ce matin à orly plusieurs syndicats
appelaient à la manifestation
les grévistes essentiellement des
personnels au sol d'orly sud et les
personnels du service de maintenance
sont eux aussi envahi une partie des
pistes
c'est le mouvement le plus dur depuis la
grève des contrôleurs aériens dans les
années 70 reportage dave m'étais et
claude sicard
il avait annoncé des rassemblement orly
puis des manifestations vers un point de
convergence sans préciser lequel
en fait ce point de convergence ce matin
que sur les trois pistes de l'aéroport
d'orly 2000 agents d'air france bloque
qu'en ce moment tout atterrissage ou
décollage de toute compagnie aérienne
le trafic est complètement paralysée
dans les deux aéroports parisiens
un boeing 747 paris new york qui aurait
dû décoller à 10h30 dès le début de la
manifestation s'est trouvée immobilisée
sur la piste contrairement à roissy où
air france avait annulé tous ses vols
d'aujourd'hui dès hier soir
l'invasion des pistes après ici les
compagnies et les passagers par surprise
pour tous renseignements deux numéros
verts sont à la disposition des
passagers pour les vols au départ
05 05 11 55 pour les vols à l'arrivée
dayraut 5 05 15 55